thank you so much to giving me the
opportunity to make a speech today
represent acha I'm sorry that after my
speech I will have to leave the room
because you call it also counting the
europe i have tomorrow an important
meeting in brussels and have a
government meeting today to prepare the
European Council of tomorrow where you
know it will be an important moment for
Europe when we speak about our friends
from the UK and also the refugee crisis
and I think it's a big challenge for all
of us you just introduced me by telling
that I was Ministry of Communication and
Media and also minister of Religious
Affairs I hope you don't see a link
between both because you forgot that I'm
also Ministry of Culture so fiercely
yeah ladies and gentlemen let me tell
you how happy I am to welcome you today
in Luxembourg to the fiber to the home
conference 2016 being able to host this
conference is a real privilege for my
country the digital revolution is
changing our life and only fiber is
providing the capacity for our networks
to support Eva increasing needs and
connectivity and believe me I leave it
sometimes in day life daily life when I
have some of my colleagues who told me
we can't use that hotel when we are
abroad and I ask why because the
internet connectivity is bad and you
will need it and realize few years ago
when you choose a hotel you would check
the location you would check if there
was a pool you would check if there was
noise now you check also if in the
comments you will read that there is no
internet or things like that this might
even influenced your choice to be
somewhere somewhere else it's a so
reality the deployment of fiber is
indeed high on the agenda in my country
even higher than in
to other countries fantastic work is
being realized even if not everybody
does share my enthusiasm right now
believe me I was the mayor of this city
before and because putting fiber into
the ground alternately doesn't go
without a lot of third noise and traffic
jams but let me take the opportunity of
your visit to Luxembourg to mention some
pieces of our history luxembourg used to
be quite famous fortress in the late
Middle Ages providing the theater for
major war scenes opposing European
military palace Army's coming from
France Germany Spain austria or bagundi
to besiege occupy or defend the rocks on
which the city of luxembourg was built
in the 19th century the fortress was
finally dismantled and neutralized by
the creation of an independent granted
she with the walls falling the tiny
country opened wide its doors to trade
and communicate which is bigger
neighbors in the 20th century iron
mining and steel mills brought wealth
into our country which is today still
the seeds of accelerometer the biggest
steel producer in the world Luxembourg
is one of the six founding members of
the European Union and has to privilege
to host a number of European
institutions among which are the
European Court of Justice the Court of
Auditors the european investment bank
and services of the European Commission
and the European Parliament it is also
the home of the active group the biggest
european private broadcaster which
started in the 30s by using Luxembourg's
radio frequencies and I just come back
from Berlin yesterday where for them a
TL was a name of freedom it was the
capacity to listen to the beatles for
the first time it was the capacity to
listen to youth from somewhere else and
for them
they also had yo dil e Luxenberg means a
lot we have a CS in Luxembourg the
leading satellite operator and believe
me when in the 80s some member of
government thought that we should invest
in satellites some people showed they
would need more apps I cotta then a bank
to help and to find financing and
nowadays we are proud to have the
worldwide coverage for TV distribution
but also internet connectivity around
the world effect is dead Luxembourg use
more space in the space than on the
ground and it's not finished Luxembourg
is of course a financial center
providing finance and banking services
to an international customer base when
the internet emerged we had soon their
mission to build on our broadcasting and
satellite assets in order to diversify
our economy and to further develop the
ICT sector but we had first our
knowledge to a knowledge that the
information highways did in fact
circumvent our territory and that we
were not really on the map of the major
data streams we soon undertook to
radically improve our international
connectivity drawing also on our central
location at the crossroads in the middle
of the major European metropole such as
Paris Frankfurt and brothel we also
started to improve connectivity within
the country putting into the ground for
the backbone building state-of-the-art
data centers attracting international
careers setting up luxembourg internet
exchange and stimulating competition on
the domestic market we finally succeeded
in being chosen as the European hub by
major internet players but we saw also
many smaller ICT companies growing and
even highly successful startups such as
Skype we're founded in Luxembourg we
were able to attract skilled talent but
we still need and it is not only in
Luxembourg the case and I remember when
I sit with Commissioner
utting on mr. colleagues on the telecom
archit i when i introduced the
presidency of Luxan like one of the
first questions some members of the
European Parliament asked me was do you
think that digital revolution will cost
jobs or create jobs both are right but
if we are not able to have the people
ready who are able to fulfill the job
and what will be needed we will lose two
jobs so we need also to realize that
it's a shame that nowadays very often
when you are successful in Europe if you
want to have a bigger market you need to
go to the States or to Asia and we need
to have a common policies and we need to
have people who will be able to be able
to take the jobs that we will be needed
in next future if we are not we will
need to have people coming from other
countries as Europe won't be ready for
it so it's very important for us to have
that on the agenda in my country for
example the multilingual political and
economic stability low electricity
prices and in outperforming electricity
grid are all part of the advent changes
you will have and you will find in
luxembourg in april 2010 the government
adopted an ambitious strategy for the
deployment of ultra high speed networks
which the stated go to become the first
favorite country in the European Union
the strategy includes quantified
objectives with deadlines aiming at a
complete coverage of the country with
network allowing speeds of 100 megabytes
per second at the end of 2015 and one
gigabyte per second at the end of 2020
not wobbling the strategy provides also
for ambitious targets not only for
download speeds but also for upload
speeds being set at fifty percent of the
download speed and up to now the
objectives have been largely fulfilled
we don't not yet have all the statistics
for the end of 2015 that admit 2015 in
more than half of
municipalities including all the biggest
at least ninety percent of all the
households had access to the connection
allowing for a download speed of hundred
megabytes per second and in all the
municipalities ninety percent or more
had access to speed of 30 megabytes per
second this result has been shipped by a
mix of technologies including
fibre-to-the-home vdsl and cable mobile
networks are of course also crucial not
only to complete the coverage but also
for communications on the move 4G has
been deployed in Luxembourg cysts 2012
but when it comes to the gigabit level
you need fiber and preferably fiber to
the home and about half of the country
is fibrous by now so we are on the right
way the strategy sets object time
objectives but not bending obligations
the progress achieved would not have
been possible without the commitment of
our history operator post Luxembourg
which had already deployed a lot of
fiber before to 10010 and which respond
positively to the strategy by
accelerating its investment it also
accepted the recommendation of the
strategy to opt for a point-to-point
network architecture which facilitates
this local long loop unbundling and
allows for enhanced competition and
hence more choice for the consumer in
addition to fixing the objectives the
strategy provides for a number of a
companion miss measures such as Public
Works registry instruction instructions
for posing ducts when you roads are
built or in new buildings further steps
will be taken soon by the adoption of a
new law transposing the so-called
European directive on cost reduction
which will also make mandatory a number
of measures which were already included
in the strategy as in Luxembourg the
ownership of the common parts of many
multi drooling buildings is in fact
shared between the owners of the
different flats which makes it
complicated to take decisions in on
in-house
cabling we have included specific
provisions to help bridging the last
step between the fiber in the basement
of the building and the homes at
different floors ladies and gentlemen
deploying fiber to the home is of course
not the final objective it is an enabler
Raider than an end in itself my
government has made the ultra high speed
broadband initiative part of the broader
strategy which we called digital nuts
bush our goal is to make use of the
infrastructure to further develop the
ICT sector to improve the
competitiveness of our economy as a wall
to increase the productivity of our
workforce or to fascinate and to
facilitate the life of our citizens we
want to make Luxembourg a smart and a
connected country luxembourg cannot
prosper alone however we are deeply
rooted in the European economy and it's
essential that our reopen partners again
into the same roots we welcome the
European Commission's digital single
market that I must be able to circulate
free and secure in the single European
market the same as for goods services
persons and capital luxembourg just
finished six months term as the
presidency of the Council of the
European Union and we are proud that we
have been able to contribute
substantially to the digital single
market by achieving the long-expected
agreement on the European data
protection regulation we have also in
completing the adoption of the
regulation abolishing the roaming
surcharges for my mobile communications
in Europe by reaching an agreement on
the directive or network and information
security we were able to secure the
timely entry into full of the eyes r
squared program on interior
interoperability and by obtaining an
agreement for the opening of discussions
with the european parliament on the
accessibility of public sector websites
i can only hope that this positive drive
can be maintained
and the fast progress on object digital
single market initiatives will be
achieved this is key for Europe and its
key for luxembourg as well we want a
smart Luxembourg within a smart Europe
being connected being able to
communicate having access to information
at all times and at any place is key for
citizens businesses but also for our
administration's and increasingly also
objects are communicating not only we
communicate with machines that they
communicate with each other video
streaming in high resolution exchanging
pictures downloading software video
conferencing teleworking telemedicine
smart mattering smart mobility and
logistics and many other applications
need increasing bandwidth we all have
multiple devices and it often happens
that many people want to use them at the
same time and at the same place the
increased capacity of our networks will
open many new opportunities which will
in turn create new needs I have no doubt
that the infrastructure that we are
putting in place today will be most
needed in a few years time and I'm sure
that this conference will help to
convince to suit out who might consider
that our goals are overly ambitious
deploying fiber is a future-proof
investment it is the key to innovation
and puts the basis for future economic
growth I would like to thank the
organizers for choosing Luxembourg to
host this conference I wish you all of
you a big big success and I know as a
public actor that you need decisions
taking by public actors but I need you I
know that I can't do it without you you
know that you can't do it without us so
let's work closer together thank you
very much